the idea of going back to westeros was
almost too much of a challenge we're
going back 200 years earlier to a time
when dragons were plenty and the iron
throne far more extravagant yes we are
looking at the coolest set pieces from
house of the dragon
number one in retrospect the throne room
was looking a bit barren so the throne
is looking a bit different these days
the reason is that the one in the
original series didn't truly honor the
vision george rr martin had for it so
the house of the dragon is going back to
the original art for the throne all we
have to wonder about is do you think
those swords are sharp given they had to
be transported with pool noodles we
think so the added swords that cascade
the stairs were partially added to
create distance between the throne and
everyone else but also to respect the
15-foot chair of swords in the books
that just wasn't practical what if there
was a whole story to tell about the kind
of devolution of the throne the throne
was always meant to be so huge it
stopped sunlight from coming in the
window number two they should put the
dragon head up for auction it would look
nice in the living room one cool dragon
head prop was definitely not cgi
something about it outside of the
context of the show just makes it seem
massive do you think the targaryens
paint dragon eggs for easter chicken
eggs just aren't half as challenging
number three hey pal you got a sword i
can borrow a whole army's worth would be
ideal imagine making that call to other
rival studios that you need every single
sword they can possibly scrounge
together that's just what house of the
dragon had to do to design the new slash
old iron throne in the image of the
initial art and descriptions they needed
2500 swords in total the extra swords
may be recognizable from the witcher and
the live-action world of warcraft movie
simply titled warcraft maybe this has
created room for a crossover or at the
very least inspired some fan art
number four and now for the castle that
houses the throne the red keep is
different from the original series not
by much but the way it was redesigned
was to interconnect all of the rooms as
if they were actually building a castle
it's all built in it's not on separate
stages which was really fun to play with
this way they can film long tracking
shots you don't have to build the whole
castle a staircase was added as a symbol
of power and gives a sense of parliament
while also being just the home of the
family new spaces were built in and the
composite allows lots of spaces for
characters to just observe what's going
on to add to the intrigue and the
conspiracy honestly people were pushing
so hard against the idea of having the
rooms attached you have to wonder what
their problem is
number five there's like over 20 dragons
in the series go big or go home the
visual effects supervisor angus
bickerton when he'd read about the
tournament thought it was going to be in
a field with some trees around it boy
was he ever wrong the tournament is
essentially playing at war they needed
their opening to be big and pay homage
to those great battle scenes game of
thrones was known for a design was done
up for the colosseum and i said
really jim
have you got the money to build that and
he goes yeah yeah
number six on to the city that harbors
the castle that houses the throne we're
making up a nursery rhyme here casores
in spain was previously used in game of
thrones for the lannister stronghold
king's landing in season seven it's
officially back for house of the dragon
or the exterior shots do you think it
would have looked the same 200 years
earlier number seven animals are a whole
other beast when it comes to filmmaking
one thing that made working in the
colosseum slightly trickier was the
horses when you've got animals involved
you need to take extra precaution to
make sure they don't hurt themselves so
they had to be certain they had soft
ground for the horses hence the mulch
that's just one of the many things we're
sure they had to do a lot of prep for
like where do the horses sleep where do
they hang out when they're not on set do
they get their own green room is it
literally a green pasture they probably
have their own trailer right
number eight sometimes you've got to
make your own creative choices
continuity is second to beautiful sets
and the statues in the throne room they
didn't exist in the original series but
were in the books and the creative team
debated whether they were changing too
much ultimately they decided
a lot can happen in 200 years and the
best explanation they've got is the
statues were stolen during the attack on
king's landing what do you think though
is continuity more important than design
let us know your thoughts in the
comments
number nine fantasy is going digital an
led video stage was built at the warner
bros leavesden studios in watford
england so that they could have their
stunning backdrops in real time this
game-changing technology is popping up
more and more leaving the dreadful green
and blue screens in the past at least
when it comes to big budget productions
number 10. do you think it's common to
alert the fire department to filming
driftmark was filmed on location on the
island of saint michael's mount in
cornwall the cornwall fire department
had to put out a public announcement
that the set would be creating
controlled plumes of smoke so that no
one in the vicinity freaked out they
collected tons of driftwood and
scattered it along the beach and then
set up shipwrecks with it sweeping
exterior shots were taken at hollywell
bay beach in cornwall they're shipping
the actors around in boats to set the
place couldn't have been very accessible
by land you'd think they'd be nervous
that the actors would get their costumes
wet in those boats but nope
number 11. imagine paying this much
attention to your extras all the time
due to covid restrictions they were only
allowed 150 extras and they needed
thousands to fill the coliseum
populating it required a ton of work
because they really didn't want to rely
on cgi we filmed the sprites from all
sorts of different angles they ensure
they film them doing all sorts of
different actions cheering shouting
sitting standing sleeping okay maybe not
sleeping
is far too interesting to fall asleep
watching besides for the common folk we
bet it's the only entertainment they get
all year
number 12. welcome to the wonderful
world of dream well there's that pesky
green screen all over the place perhaps
we aren't finished with it yet we're
starting to think the leds are favorable
when your backgrounds move and may be
less necessary when they don't either
way the final product or should we say
the initial product is gorgeous
number 13 filming hasn't changed all
that much since the days of harry potter
here is how they set up the dragon
flight simulation they had a half-baked
cgi render of the dragon only seen
through the camera lens because
apparently their led panels aren't good
enough to forego green screen here
either and milly alcock was propped up
on a giant saddle rig at least harry
potter had the audacity to actually
build their dragons though come on house
of dragon we want real dragons
number 14 it wouldn't be a game of
thrones prequel without a giant battle
it's fun to get a glimpse at everything
that goes into crafting a battle scene
from the long track shots to the giant
fan that we swore was a giant hamster
wheel for a second number 15. 200 years
earlier the trees were much happier
another weirwood tree has made an
appearance or at least half of it has
but this one is looking a little less
depressed than the one we saw in got
house of the dragon is bigger sharper
and full of more dragons it's shaping up
to be a fantastic series what could go
wrong are you excited about the new
changes they've made or do you miss the
understated iron throne let us know in
the comments and thanks for hanging out
with us here at the things
you